[Applause]
thank you
thank you everyone please
[Applause]
thank you thank you for the incredibly
warm reception it is great to be among
so many fellow conservatives now let me
also just say a lot a lot has happened
since we were lost all together
we're providing incredible support
to help families with the cost of living
fifteen hundred pounds around half
typical family's Energy bill
we're strengthening our security or the
landmark new defense agreement with
Australia
and America
we're joining
the trans-pacific trade partnership
trillions of pounds linking us to the
fastest growing economies in the world
and finally
Nicholas sturgeon has quit Butte house
to take up driving lessons
[Applause]
oh I tell you I tell you because because
someone's got to drive that motor home
after all
now I wanted to start by paying tribute
to Douglas now A couple of years ago
Douglas fought very hard to deny Nicola
sturgeon the majority that she wanted
and with all of your help he did that
and imagine how different things would
have been if she'd got that majority she
would have pushed an even more divisive
agenda
but that didn't happen you changed the
course and now she's gone so I think all
of you want to join me in saying thank
you to Douglas
Doug Douglas has brought by a great team
of councilors and msps here but I also
wanted to take a second to say thank you
to my dear friend and your Scottish
secretary Aleister Jack now Alistair is
not only not only an incredible voice
for Scotland around the cabinet table I
know like me you would have all felt
felt an enormous sense of Pride when you
saw Alistair as a member of the company
of archers representing Scotland
standing guard around her late Majesty's
coffin in Westminster Hall Aleister
thank you for everything that you do
now it it used to be that the SMP
couldn't focus on Scotland's priorities
because they were obsessed about
independence now even they admit that
there is not a sustained majority in
support of Independence and yet they're
still distracted
and as many of you have rightly said if
the SMP can't sort out the mess
that Nicola sturgeon left their party
how on Earth can they sort out the mess
that Nicholas sturgeon has left
Scotland's public services in
what
what we need is a government in
Hollywood that is focused on Scottish
people's real priorities not
constitutional abstractions
now the SNP may not be able to find some
Auditors for their party but we can
certainly audit their record in
government
just take a look at the education
attainment Gap the very thing that
Nicholas sturgeon said that they should
be judged on
that Gap widening
violent crime
Rising and they can't even deliver the
fairies that they've promised the
Islanders it is a record of failure and
one that Douglas and all of you have
done wonders to call out and hold them
accountable for now meanwhile we've been
getting on delivering just this week
almost three quarters of a million
Scottish families receiving direct
financial help with the cost of living
just like during the pandemic with
furlough
you saw the power and the might of the
UK government to support the most
vulnerable families in Scotland
demonstrating
demonstrating the benefit of Scotland
being inside our precious United Kingdom
[Applause]
now at the beginning of the year I set
out five priorities
the Hall of inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting list and to stop
the boats
I know
that we can move forward and make sure
that those things happen I'm confident
that that's what we'll do and just
imagine how different politics will feel
with inflation falling and low again the
economy growing again Public Services
back to where we want them to be
postcovid
and I know that because I only promise
what I can deliver and I will deliver
what I promise
[Applause]
thank you
and Scotland is at the heart of my plans
for delivery that's why the chancellor
came here to announce the Edinburgh
reforms in Scotland supporting
Scotland's Financial Services industry
which is World leading and we want to
create the jobs of the future and make
sure that industry remains competitive
it's why we're funding
a supercomputer in Scotland to take
advantage of all the Innovation that the
modern economy is going to see and need
it's why we're spending over a billion
pounds in towns and communities and
Villages up and down Scotland to support
local projects through leveling up
it's why we alone are the party that
supports Scotland's naughty oil and gas
industry because we know we need to
increase our energy security not
increase our Reliance on Vladimir Putin
[Applause]
and and it's why when I was last here we
announced the creation of two new
freeports what a fantastic example of a
conservative government delivering for
the people of Scotland two free ports
with new funding
special economic zones that will attract
investment increased trade and most
crucially create jobs for our young
people in the industries of the future
and that in a nutshell is what we are
about that is the vision that the
conservatives deliver
it's a future for our young people that
is filled with opportunity filled with
hope filled with optimism a confidence
that that future will be better for the
next Generation that it is today that is
what the conservatives deliver in
government
and I'll say this to conclude
under my leadership we will never ever
forget that we are the conservative and
unionist party
and working together
all of us
proudly as conservatives we will deliver
for each and every part of our precious
United Kingdom thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank you now
[Applause]
Douglas
resilience was not going to allow me to
leave without answering all of your
questions so here he is with a very long
clipboard very long prime minister every
week I ask a political leader a series
of questions and very rarely get answers
so I'm looking forward to the to hear
your answers on a number of questions
that's been submitted from our members
but maybe first of all for me you spoke
about your priorities and the five
priorities of you and your government
and how you're going to achieve those
here in Scotland we don't have that we
don't have priorities from the s p from
Hamza Yusuf how how do we manage that
how do we look at the leadership you're
providing at a UK level and the
distraction we're getting from the real
priorities from the Scottish government
here well I think Douglas you you guys
do a great job here of holding the SMP
government to account and that's what
you should be doing and whether it's on
schools whether it's on the NHS whether
it's on crime you know all things that
the Scottish government is in control of
not the UK government it's right that
you call out their record on all of
these things and you're doing it
brilliantly and people can see that now
when it comes to the priorities that
we've set out they're actually you know
in the most part apply to the entire
country you know the exception obviously
of the NHS which is a devolved
responsibility but if you look at the
first three they're all economic and
that is deliberate because right now if
you talk to anybody in any part of the
United Kingdom the issue that they care
most about is the cost of living and I
think that's where all of us can
demonstrate to the people of Scotland
what we are doing to help ease the
burden on the cost of living I talked
about the 1500 pounds that's the value
of the support we're providing right now
to a typical family in Scotland it's
about half of their energy bill that the
UK government is bearing the cost of
because these are exceptional times I
talked about what we're doing just this
week for the most vulnerable families
they're receiving extra help the first
of those payments went out this week to
almost three quarters of a million
Scottish people more to come later this
year pensioners later now that's a UK
government getting on and standing
behind the people of Scotland and over
the course of the year as we see
inflation come down we'll all be able to
stand up and say to the people our plan
worked you can feel that it's working
you'll feel that you have more money in
your bank account at the end of every
month and that's something that we will
have done as conservatives and had
nothing to do with the SMP absolutely
absolutely we've had so many questions
in from members in the hall and across
Scotland who have wanted to put some
points to you so let me first of all go
to mark from Edinburgh he's asked about
your government's approach to dealing
with the SMP with the Scottish
government uh clearly Scotland has two
governments and most people want the
governments to work together but we in
this room and the majority of people
across Scotland also want you to
continue to hold firm against their
plans for another divisive Independence
referendum you may at terms of use of
earlier on this week how do you balance
that between holding firm on the union
but working constructively where you can
with the Scottish government you know I
think you just summarized it Douglas
that's exactly what we need to do when I
saw him
I was completely firm about independence
and I will always be completely firm
that's not a priority of the Scottish
people as as he himself admitted over
the summer I think he said there's no
sustained majority for Independence and
they would do well to remember that and
stop being distracted and obsessing
with it but as as we have all worked
together very well you and Alistair me
and and Michael Gove as well you know
we're very clear that we want to
demonstrate to the people of Scotland
that we can and we will work
constructively together with the
Scottish government to deliver for the
people of Scotland because I think as
you said Douglas that's what they want
so freeports are a good example of that
that was a UK government idea to
post-brexit opportunity and through
slightly tortuous process that Alistair
had to run finally the SMP accepted that
actually it was a good thing because the
businesses and people of Scotland all
wanted it to happen in Scotland they
didn't want to be left behind the rest
of the UK and they agreed in the end and
that's why we're now delivering to
freeports that's a great way for us to
demonstrate our willingness to work
constructively together and I think
ultimately that's in our long-term
political interests to show people that
that's what we're about lots of our
members have put in questions about
Devolution including Sheila from
Sterling she's asked what do you see as
a way forward for Devolution in Scotland
so I'd say a couple of things one is we
can't devolve and forget right so
Scotland already is the most powerful
devolved assembly anywhere in the world
so all this talk of needing any more
Powers is clearly not appropriate right
it doesn't even use all the Scott the S
P and the Scottish government don't even
use all the powers they already have so
we shouldn't stop talking about any more
what we need to do is hold them to
account as we're all doing and we're
we're going to do some things I talked
about it with you over the summer how
can we make it easier to hold the
Scottish government to account to make
sure that there's comparability of data
across the UK something you've talked a
lot about in your colleagues in the
Scottish Parliament how can we make sure
that we can compare what's going on in
every part of the UK so we can
practically make a difference there but
also we believe in real Devolution as
conservatives you know we believe
decisions should be made as close to
people as possible and we know that in
the same way that Westminster doesn't
always know best it's not the case that
in Scotland that the SMP and and the
Hollywood government always know best so
what we believe is we can devolve power
to local communities and that's what
we've done and it's something that you
and Alistair championed rightly so now
the UK government is being far more
engaged and involved when it comes to
leveling up investing directly in local
communities across Scotland and I think
as you've all seen that's been really
healthy it's been brilliant because
those local councils those local
communities are really Keen to engage
with the UK government they know what
the priorities of their local areas are
more so than Nicholas sturgeon and the
SMP do and they've responded really well
to that and it's a way for us to
demonstrate the benefit of the UK
government in Scotland we don't have to
just hand everything over to the
Scottish government and I think that's
real Devolution right there's Devolution
in action at a very local level yeah and
sticking with Devolution uh because of
the tax-fading powers Scotland under the
s p is the highest tax part of the
United Kingdom Jones from Peebles and
and from Aberdeen are asking what would
you say to those who are concerned about
the impact that's having on individuals
and businesses here in Scotland well it
is having an impact and then when I'm
here and I talk to businesses and I talk
to people they raise it proactively with
me I mean it's not a great tagline
Scotland's the highest tax place inside
the United Kingdom right it's not a
great adverb and you all have done a
brilliant job of pointing that out
holding the SMP government to account
for it and what I want to do over time
I've said this I've said it as
Chancellor I've said it as prime
minister the chancellor said it our
desire is conservatives is to reduce the
burden of tax on working people right
that's what we all believe now we know
things are difficult right now and we're
and we're getting through the aftermath
of covid and the inflation pressures
that we're seeing from Ukraine and
Russia's Invasion but look when we can
of course we want to reduce taxes
because as conservatives we all know we
want people to have more money in their
own Pockets we trust them to spend it
better than the government and it's
clear that the s p don't believe that
and we shouldn't Tire of pointing that
out yeah and and Taxation may come into
to this next question Cameron from
Inverness has asked how can we ensure
that young aspirational professionals
remain here in Scotland
you know I I'm I'm actually really
positive that we can do that because of
the incredible strengths and talents of
the people in Scotland and the Ingenuity
of your businesses if you think about it
I talk about financial services right
it's no accident that Chancellor came
here to announce his uh changes to
financial services regulation it's
because you've got one of the most
amazing Financial Services sectors
anywhere in the UK full of really and
it's not just the big companies it's
full of young interesting startups
entrepreneurial companies involved in
fintech now that's why I think as we can
take advantage of brexit Reform
regulations make sure that this is the
best place to start to grow a company
then we will be able to keep those young
people here in Scotland and that's my
vision then when someone asked me what
does leveling up mean to you that's what
I say I say it means that you've got to
be able to fulfill all your dreams in
the place that you grew up in you
shouldn't have to leave and that is
definitely the case here and with our
policies with the things we're doing to
you know to support entrepreneurship
that's the way that we can build quite
an attractive opportunity set for young
people and again the Chancellor's
announcement of a supercomputer being
funded here in in Scotland you know that
just speaks to your Innovation economy
that's how we create the jobs of the
future it all comes out of innovation
and that Innovation is happening here
because of the talent of the Scottish
people so I'm incredibly excited about
it but as you say it's the SMP
government's policies whether it's on
tax and regulation that are damaging
that business confidence our job is to
ensure that we can keep promoting that
you speak about fulfilling your dreams
that's what leveling up is all about I
think okay Michael Gove takes out quite
an extreme extent when he goes to the
dance floor every time he's back in
Aberdeen that's clearly fulfilling his
dreams there and we we've discussed at
jobs and you mentioned in your remarks
about the energy sector and we've had a
lot of comments on this it's Sandy from
forkerberg's mg from hopeman so very
strong Murray it links here it Baker
from East cobraid and Daniela from
Aberdeen all asked about the support for
nuclear renewable energy and oil and gas
what's your government doing on these
issues well we've we've I saw him
somewhere where is he there he is you
know Andrew Bowie in his new job does
everyone know this he's got a new name
his his new name Grant chaps calls him
Atomic Bowie and that's because he's our
one-man advocate for the nuclear
industry as well as the oil and gas
industry now look I this is this is
probably one of the most exciting
economic opportunities for the UK but
for Scotland specifically and
in all those industries that you
mentioned but in particular carbon
capture and storage hydrogen offshore
wind now we are already either world
leaders right or we're going to be you
look at offshore wind not only does the
UK home to the largest offshore Wind
Farm it's also home to the second
largest the third largest the fourth
largest right and that is thanks to
Scottish Ingenuity carbon capture and
storage look across Europe I think
something like 80 for Android correctly
if I'm wrong but they're like 85 of all
of Europe's storage capacity for carbon
capture and storage is in the North Sea
and that's why we're doing the free
ports that's why we're investing in r d
and you know I have this Vision someone
said it to me and I think we can do it
right it was once upon a time when it
came to oil and gas it was Scottish
voices that you could hear across the
world because we figured out how to do
it here you all figured out how to do it
and then we exported that talent that
technology that expertise to everywhere
else we're going do that again Scotland
is going to do that again in all these
new industries of the future and that's
why we're the government that can
deliver it because we understand it and
I mentioned it in my remarks right we're
the only party that unequivocally
supports the naughty industry right I
mean it's extraordinary when we've got a
war going on which has highlighted the
issue of being dependent on places like
Russia for fossil fuels that these other
polities think
that we should ignore what we have at
home ignore the economic benefits that
jobs ignore the energy security and
increase our Reliance on foreign
dictators for energy that we know we
need for the next couple of decades and
by the way all the skills in that
industry are transferable to all these
new Industries so I think I think when
this incredibly important area that we
are absolutely the party that's going to
deliver and it's going to be incredibly
exciting for Scotland absolutely
and the Applause here rightly started by
Greg Hunt who before he became UK party
chairman an outstanding energy Minister
who came here took the fight the SNP
here in Scotland and has been laying
this out for many many years you've
mentioned it and not to give too much
away and there'll be more on that in my
speech uh later on this afternoon as
well but when we speak about offshore
energy and the potential with Renewables
here there's also an outstanding
industry in Scotland around the fishing
sector so Elizabeth from peterhead has
asked how can the UK government support
funding and further funding for the
fishing industry to make sure that
benefits communities in the North and
the northeast of Scotland yeah now
Elizabeth that's an excellent question
and you know you should know that we are
absolutely standing behind the fishing
industry we created this UK Seafood fund
and I think it's Scotland is getting a
large chunk of that over the next couple
of years you guys probably the numbers
better than me but it's something like
40 million pounds over the next couple
of years is being invested in the
Scottish fishing industry and it's going
into all the things that you would
expect it to be going into how do we
develop skills for the Next Generation
how do we improve the productivity and
support all these small businesses often
family businesses to expand their
manufacturing and their capabilities so
actually some of the Investments we've
made I think one has been in peterhead
in particular another one in Fort
William from memory but those are the
types of places that are receiving
investment from this fund to help those
small and medium-sized businesses in
expand now obviously also because of
brexit you know we've increased all the
quotas that we have access to and in
particular I think the one that we spend
a lot of time talking about at the time
was mackerel which is one of our most
valuable
um uh fishing stocks but also the one
where Scottish fleets are dominant
something like 90 of the mackerel is is
called by Scottish fleets and because of
what we've been able to do post-brexit
the value of that catch has gone up by
40 50 million pounds a year so it's a
great opportunity but that's why we need
to invest in support the small and
medium-sized businesses in it to take
advantage of that opportunity so that's
what we're going to do and and rest
assured you know I I come from a rural
constituency landlocked
um but you know whether it's farming
whether it's fishing these are things
that I care about deeply and I'll make
sure that we continue to support them
and again one of those things that we
all know in this room that's something
that the conservatives understand deeply
and it's not something that the SMP or
labor will ever prioritize and indeed we
can see the SMP actually being
counterproductive to the Fisheries of
the protection so yeah opportunities
from the UK government but with hpmes
with catching limits and such like I was
up in Shetland a couple of weeks ago and
the fishermen were crying out for a
voice in the Scottish Parliament because
they know they're not getting that from
the s p now greens and government Rachel
Hamilton our rural Affairs spokesperson
is doing great work on that and again
come back tomorrow we're doing a lot of
rural discussions in our second day
tomorrow here in Glasgow yeah we've just
done that Douglas I was just really paid
tribute to everyone well these hpmas
you've done an excellent job of calling
about the challenges with those and and
again I know that fishing industry is
deeply grateful but it's a great example
the same on DRS and we were talking
about it in pmqs over the last couple of
weeks you know look you know you should
all feel incredibly proud right the
Scottish conservatives you you took the
lead in calling out that that scheme was
not something that was going to be
workable that it was going to increase
costs for Scottish consumers for
businesses reduce choice right and
because of that sustained campaign
ultimately what you've seen is they've
paused they've delayed they're reforming
right and that is just shows that we're
the ones who have got the Scottish
people's interests at heart we
understand their priorities and we're
the ones that have better place to
deliver for them absolutely
we we have rattled through a range of
issues from lots of different members
across Scotland I'm being told we've got
one last question that we've got time
for so Duncan from Glasgow and we're
delighted to have you here in Glasgow
for a conference they really buoyed by
your remarks and your answers it's the
questions the final question comes from
Duncan who asks what can we do to win
the next general election
now I a couple of things what look one
we've got to deliver for people and that
ultimately is the most important thing
right and that's why I've talked about
the five priorities you know you'll have
a set of things that you want to focus
on here as well but we must deliver for
people and demonstrate to them that we
as a conservative government are just
making their lives better I think and
I'm sure you'd agree with me people have
had quite enough of politics politicians
and political chat over the last year or
two what they want is tangible action
and that's what we're gonna set about
doing and the last thing I'd say though
and this is probably the most important
thing and you've done brilliantly at
this over the last few years is we've
got to have belief
all right we've got to have belief
now it comes it starts in the cabinet it
goes down all the way to every Council
that we have to all of you out there
knocking on doors have the confidence
and belief and there's no reason for us
not to because we know that our values
are the values of the British people we
know that our priorities are their
priorities
and we know when we can see that we are
the ones that will keep delivering for
them and making their lives better and
just have that in your head go out there
with good heart and good share and if we
do that over the coming months I'm
absolutely convinced that we can win
that next general election and we're
going to do it working very hard
together thanks very much
thank you
[Applause]